القوات البرية السعودية فقط
لوحدها.
هذا عرضنا واحد. ودمنا واحد. يا
سعودي. سلمت محاصر.
بخصوص ايران. لا نريد ان نكرر
اتفاق حدث في عام ثمانية وثلاثين
وكان نتيجة الالتزام فيه حرب
عالمية ثانية.
وبعد ان كانا سيتقاتلان ها هما
اليوم يتعانقان. نعم فلنطوي صفحة
الماضي ومرحبا بالحاضر هكذا
قالتها الصين للجارتين الاعداء
ونقصد هنا ايران والسعودية. فمن
يصدق? امريكا هنا بتلك الزاوية
تتحسر على ورقتها التي احرقتها
الصين. وكاني اشتم رائحة روسيا
فقبل اعلان التصالح بساعات ها
هما وزيرا الخارجية السعودي
والروسي يتبادلان الضحكات. ومن
بين ركام الخلافات العقائدية
والسياسية. الصين وروسيا ترتبان
صفوف العالم الجديد ان نقول
وداعا للهيمنة الامريكية وقبل
فلنقف ونصفق لاصحاب العيون
الضيقة فقد صنعوا معجزة سياسية
وجعلوا الخلافات منسية فما الذي
حدث? يوم امريكا الاسود. بعد
عداء دام اكثر من اربعين عاما
بين السعودية وايران. ذلك العداء
الذي لطالما الهب المنطقة
بشرارات الحروب. يبدو ان الصين
استطاعت استخدام ذلك العداء في
صفعة مؤلمة على وجه الولايات
المتحدة الامريكية وسحب البساط
من تحت قدميها في المنطقة.
وكانها تقول للوحش الامريكي
المرعب. لا مكان لكم هنا. فهل
تعجل بنقل عفشكم. ولم تمض ايام
قليلة على الوساطة الصينية بين
السعودية وايران برعاية الرئيس
الصيني نفسه شي جين بينغ لاصلاح
الامور وانهاء الخلافات بين
البلدين. فوجئ منذ ساعات قليلة.
ببيان مشترك من الدول الثلاث
يعلنون فيه نجاح المفاوضات
والمبادرة الصينية في انهاء
الخلافات السعودية الايرانية
وعودة العلاقات بين البلدين. وتم
الاتفاق على اعادة فتح القنصليات
والسفارات المشتركة بينهما في
غضون شهرين على الاكثر. وكان
لسان حال السعودية يقول لايران
بالاحضان يا عدوي العزيز. هناك
عدو مشترك يتربص بنا علينا
القضاء عليه اولا ولكن ما هي
كلمة السر في نجاح الوساطة
الصينية. الضمان الصيني. لم تكن
الوساطة الصينية هي الاولى من
نوعها لانهاء العداء بين
السعودية وايران. فسنوات العداء
الطويلة بين البلدين تخللها
الكثير من الوساطات لانهاء
الخلاف بينهما ولكن فشلت جميعها
ولنفس السبب وهو ان السعودية لا
تأمن غدر ايران فمن يضمن لها
بارا اذا ما نقضت ايران العهود
وكما هو حال السعودية نجد نفس
الحال في ايران فكل طرف يتهم
الاخر بعدم الايفاء بالعهود لتجد
السعودية وايران ضالتهما في
الصين. فعندما تعلن دولة بحجم
الصين انها تضمن للسعودية ضار من
غدر ايران وتضمن لايران ظهرها من
غدر السعودية. فبالطبع لن تجرؤ
اي من الدولتين على مجرد التفكير
في نقض الاتفاقيات. لانها ان
فعلت ستجد نفسها تواجه الجحيم
الصيني وغضب الدب الروسي. فنحن
نتحدث عن خارطة التحالفات
الجديدة يا سادة. لذا كان الضمان
الصيني للطرفين هو كلمة السر في
نجاح المفاوضات التي لطالما فشلت
على مدار عشرات السنين. فقد كسرت
الصين حجتهما. صفعة على وجه
امريكا. ما فعلته الصين ووساطتها
في الصلح بين السعودية وايران.
اقل ما يقال عنه انه اكبر صفعة
سياسية اصابت وجه الولايات
المتحدة في القرن الواحد
والعشرين. فالولايات المتحدة
كانت المستفيد الاكبر من بين
البلدين فقد كانت تحصل على
مليارات الدولارات من السعودية
لانعاش الاقتصاد الامريكي مقابل
حمايتها لها من الخطر الايراني.
كما كانت تهدد ايران في
المفاوضات الخاصة ببرنامجها
النووي. اي انها ان لم تخضع
لاوامرها فسوف تستغل الاموال
السعودية في تمويل حملة عسكرية
لضربها. فهي تبحث لتمول بنكها
الزمني من اجل ان تنهي النووي.
اما الان ومع الوضع الجديد وعودة
العلاقات بين البلدين لا اموال
سعودية ستنعش الاقتصاد الامريكي
مقابل الحماية ولا تهاون من
ايران في مفاوضاتها النووية.
واصبحت الولايات المتحدة نفسها
تحت التهديد. لتحرق الصين ورقة
العداء الايراني السعودي التي
كانت تضغط بها الولايات المتحدة
على دول المنطقة فاصحاب العيون
الضيقة لا يمزحون. ولكن ما الذي
يجبر السعودية وايران على انهاء
الخلافات بينهما? هل هي القوة
الصينية? ام ان الامر كان له
حسابات اخرى? السعودية تقطف
ثمارها السياسية? في الحقيقة لم
تستخدم الصين اسلوب القوة او
التهديد في اجبار البلدين على
الموافقة على الصلح ولكن الظروف
والحسابات السياسية من فعلت ذلك.
فالصلح مع ايران يعني خروج
السعودية من مستنقع اليمن
المكلف. ففي البداية ظنت
السعودية ان حربها ضد الحوثيين
لن تأخذ وقتا طويلا وانها سوف
تحقق نصرا سريعا وسهلا ولكن
تحولت الحرب الى كارثة عسكرية
واقتصادية وانسانية. ومستنقع
انها كخزانة المملكة طيلة ثماني
سنوات. ومنذ بداية الحرب عام
الفين وخمسة عشر تنفق السعودية
ما بين خمسة الى ستة مليارات
دولار شهريا حتى هذه اللحظة في
شراء السلاح ودعم الجيش السعودي
وجيش الحكومة اليمنية المدعومة
سعوديا في ضرب الحوثيين. بينما
لا تنفق ايران اي تمويل رسمي
للحوثيين. فيما تتهمها قوى دولية
بينها السعودية التي تفرض حصارا
شاملا على اليمن تتهمها بارسال
الاسلحة الهندسية لجماعة الحوثي.
والتي تعمل على تعليم الحوثيين
على صناعة الصواريخ بعيدة المدى
والطائرات المسيرة في حربهم ضد
المملكة ولكن لم تتمكن الرياض من
اثبات اي من ذلك حتى الان. ومن
اكبر اهداف السعودية ايقاف
التهديدات الامنية لمنشآتها
النفطية. في عام الفين وتسعة عشر
تعرضت منشآت نفطية في السعودية
لهجوم ادى الى نصف انتاج المملكة
من النفط وتكرر الامر ذاته في
عام الفين واثنين وعشرين. وبعيدا
عن استهداف ارامكو ولا تستعد
السعودية لانشاء مشروعات ضخمة
لجذب السياح والمستثمرين وتنويع
مصادر اقتصادها. وبالتالي فان
تلك التهديدات لا بد ان تتوقف
باي شكل. ولا نغفل ايضا عن علاقة
المملكة المتوترة مع المتحدة.
فمنذ ان اعتلى الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن رأس السلطة بدأ في
انتقاد السعودية بشدة ووجه لها
العديد من التصريحات الهجومية
وقال انه سيعمل على اعادة تقييم
العلاقات مع السعودية. الامر
الذي دفع السعودية لانتهاج سياسة
اقل عدوانية مع ايران. فقد ايقنت
السعودية ان الدعم الامريكي لها
سيتوقف لا محالة وما هي الا
مسألة وقته تبدأ السعودية صحوتها
وتدق باب الصين. والهدف انشاء
مصانع سلاح خاصة بها لتتخلص من
شراء الاسلحة من امريكا ودول
الغرب. وبالتالي فهي تحتاج الى
حليف قوي لها في المنطقة. على ان
تكون علاقة هذا الحليف مع
الولايات المتحدة ليست جيدة
تماما. ونقصد هنا روسيا والصين.
ولا نستبعد ان هذا التحالف لن
يقف انشاء مصانع الاسلحة. فقد
يتطور الامر الى مد السعودية
باسلحة نووية. ونحن نتحدث عن
خارطة التحالفات الجديدة
مستقبلا. كان هذا بعض ما ستجنيه
السعودية من صلحها مع ايران.
فماذا ستجني ايران من هذا الصلح?
استفادة ايران. اول الثمار التي
ستجنيها ايران من صلحها مع
السعودية هي انهاء عزلتها
ومساعدة في ضائقتها الاقتصادية
وكسر طوق الحصار الذي اطبقته
امريكا على عنقها. فمع زيادة
التدخل الايراني في العديد من
دول المنطقة كالعراق وسوريا
ولبنان واليمن ازدادت عزلة ايران
الدولية وانهكت تلك التدخلات
الاقتصاد الايراني بشكل كبير.
الامر الذي دفع الكثيرين من
الشعب الايراني للتظاهر ضد
حكومته وزعزعة استقرار البلاد.
وهنا ياتي دور الصلح السعودية
التي كانت الداعمة الاساسية
والدولي لهذه التظاهرات. وذلك
حسب تصريح الرئيس الايراني. بهذه
الخطوة ستخفف العزلة الايرانية
مع باقي دول المنطقة وستساعد
السلطة في ايران على ان تثبت
لشعبها ان الاوضاع الاقتصادية
المتردية التي يعيشونها لا دخل
لها بالتدخلات الايرانية في دول
المنطقة المجاورة. كما تريد
ايران استغلال هذا الصلح التوصل
لاتفاق نووي جيد بالنسبة لها.
فايران ترى ان صلحها مع السعودية
سيخفف عنها الكثير من العقوبات
الاقتصادية التي فرضتها الولايات
المتحدة عليها. وبالتالي فعودة
العلاقات مع السعودية تعد ورقة
رابحة في ايدي ايران في
مفاوضاتها النووية. وعلينا ايضا
ان لا نغفل العلاقة مع اسرائيل.
فايران تخشى انضمام السعودية الى
الدول اعلنت تطبيع العلاقات مع
اسرائيل وترى ان هذا الصلح قد
يساعدها الى حد ما في ايقاف
تطبيع السعودية مع اسرائيل
وحرمان اسرائيل من تلك القوة
التي كانت ستضاف لها اذا ما قررت
السعودية انشاء علاقات طبيعية
معها. الكل ضد امريكا. وبرغم ما
سوف تجنيه السعودية وايران هناك
دول عديدة اخرى ثمار هذا الصنع.
فالصين وروسيا ستضمنان ضعف
التدخل الامريكي في مناطق
نفوذهما. لا سيما في وقت الحرب
ضد اوكرانيا. وبلوغ علاقة الصين
وروسيا مع الولايات المتحدة
والغرب اقصى درجات الحدية
والتوتر. ولطالما استغلت
الولايات المتحدة الخلاف السعودي
الايراني في تفريق دول المنطقة.
ولكن الان لا حلفاء اقوياء
للولايات في الخليج فالكل اصبح
ضد امريكا يبدو ان هذا الصلح
الاقليمي سيكون له اثر عظيم في
قلب موازين اكبر حرب يخوضها
الغرب في القرن الواحد والعشرين.
والان كيف ترون الصلح السعودي
الايراني وما هو تأثيره المتوقع
على باقي الدول وموازين القوى في
العالم. اخبروا